Good morning Hank it’s
Tuesday May 18th
which means the Anthropocene
Reviewed book is out today.
I have to do a TV thing
I am somewhat nervous about.
But first, a while back I
discussed the strange joy of
having my books go to places
I will never go.
Like starting
today the book has a life
separate from its author and it
gets to go on all kinds of adventures
around the world forging
whatever connections it can from
whoever reads it.
Anyways,
in response to my talking about
that, Nerdfighters Jim and Rhett
made theanthropocenereviewed.com,
a domain name I am now very
grateful I never bought, and
built a website where people
can share the approximate
location of their books and also
review that location.
It has
been such a joy to watch the
books start to travel and this
morning to start to read your
reviews of your locations.
So if you have a moment go
to the anthropocenereviewed.com
and let people know where your
book ended up.
Also share a
picture of your signature if you
got an autographed one.
I’m very interested to know where
all the signatures went.
Ok I have to go do this TV thing.
Cut to me looking nervous.
Here we are, I’m getting my
makeup done Hank.
This is my favorite thing.
It feels like a nice
person is putting a protective
shield on me.
That’s how I always feel when I’m
getting my makeup done.
And I’m ready.
There’s also a
discord channel where you can
discuss the book with other
people in the community,
link in the dooblydoo.
Also,
reviews are coming in and
so far they are very nice,
like San Francisco chronicle
said, I want to make sure I
quote this correctly:
“The Anthropocene Reviewed is the
perfect book to read over lunch
or to keep on your nightstand
whenever you need a reminder
of what it is to feel small and
human in the best possible way.”
By the way that review also says,
Green is a ravenous and tender
polymath.
Which is very kind even
though I feel like proper polymaths
know how to say that word, and
I’ve never been totally confident
about my pronunciation of it.
Ok now I really have to
do this TV thing.
Here’s a
picture of Drew Barrymore
hugging my book after he said
she loved it so that was nice.
I’m back.
I hope that TV thing
went ok, but the most important
thing is that it’s over and I am
where I belong, in my basement.
Also another great review
just came in, I hope you don’t
mind if I read a little bit of it, it
made me really happy.
“Lyrical
and beautiful, funny and hopefully,
intricate and entertaining all
at once, Green may have made
his name by writing fiction and
for good reason, but this first
foray into non fiction is his
most mature, compelling, and
beautifully written book yet.”
What else?
The virtual tour
started last night with the
brilliant Clint Smith, and it was
so fun that for a little while I
forgot I was even on zoom.
The tour rolls on tonight with
special guest radio lab co-host
Latif Nasser and Sarah Urist Green.
And then on Wednesday with
Hank and Sarah, and then on
Saturday with Ashley C Ford
and Sarah.
It’s going to be
a lot of fun!
Tickets
in the dooblydoo.
It’s been a long 3 years and a
really, really long year and a
half and I’m just so grateful that the
book is here.
I wrote the book
because I wanted to write my
way back to wonder, and hope,
and sustained attention.
And it
gave me that gift.
And I hope it can give you
something of that gift too.
Last thing from me, and it may not
be easy for me to say, but Hank this
book started with you.
It started
with big, sprawling conversations
about our human moment and
how to make sense of it, and it
started with belly laughs on a
tour bus during a cross country
road trip.
Like so much of my
work and life, it starts with you.
There’s a long standing inside
joke around here that the
protagonists of all my novels
are only children because I
don’t like to write about siblings,
but that’s not true.
The truth is that
writing about siblings is too
close to my vulnerable and
beating heart.
This book finally
does have a main character with a sibling,
and you are at the beginning and
middle and end of it, telling me
what I need to hear with wit and
empathy and love, just like in real life.
I loved writing about you almost as
much as I love and miss being
able to hang out with you so thank you,
thank you for inspiring this book
and for supporting me every step of
the way.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you Hank I’ll
see you on Friday.